kelly is with us Kelly is in Orlando
Florida hi Kelly how are you hi I'm
great how are you better than I deserve
what's up I want to cut straight to the
point I went through your financial
University with my husband we let
stupidity come into our lives we bought
a $40,000 truck and then we turned
around not even a year later about 175
thousand dollar home my husband
currently is the only one bringing in an
income of right around 57,000 I did try
to sign an online eBay selling things
I'm to the point now it's like I'm
treading through water and I'm not
getting the head and I'm to the point
should we let the car company repossess
the truck should we try to sell it out
as we are in the hole right around
10,000 on it your household downtown is
going again right around 57,000 and you
bought a $40,000 truck yes stupidity
move it we should have bought the house
and we did and I mean I realized we were
so over our head I mean we still are but
I'm to the point now of just they can
have the truck back because between a
house payment and the truck it's almost
2,000 a month and I'm just I'm drowning
in debt I can't do it no more
I don't want to let the truck get
repossessed and apparently he's not
helping at all you know not really no I
mean isn't is it the best option to give
the trust like repossessed or no sell it
and pay the difference you sell it and
pay the difference because when you give
it to them they're gonna sell it for
$10,000 less than you would have sold it
for and they're gonna sue you for the
difference you get to pay the difference
either way but you're going to have more
difference and screwed up credit with a
repossession than you are if you sell it
yourself the problem is I don't think
you guys are gonna do any of this
because I think I think I think you're
gonna look at him and say we're gonna
sell the house and sell the truck and he
says no we're not and so they're going
to come take
both because y'all are not willing to
address the issue that's how you got in
this mess in the first place him I mean
he seems where we have an issue and we
we do have like 2002 see where you have
an issue he doesn't want to sell the
truck that's a lie right you're kidding
yourself
so I predict more pain until somebody
wakes up named him okay I sure hope I'm
wrong let me tell you if both of you
woke up if I can throw enough hot water
cold water or whatever kind of water I
need to throw on you guys to wake you
two up this time then you need to put
for sale sign on both of these and get
rid of them immediately
they're both insanity house and car
their insanity when you did it their
insanity to keep them you know that you
knew therefore you call me you told me
they were insanity now the only question
is are you gonna pretend like this is
not gonna happen and wait for it to
happen cuz it's gonna happen
this stuff is leaving your life they're
either going to take it or you're gonna
sell it and you're gonna decide whether
it's going to happen to you and you're
gonna be a victim or whether you're
gonna happen to it and clean up your own
mess if I'm in your shoes I'm putting
everything up for sale today and it
sounds like you two need to sit down the
marriage counselor because man I don't
know where this guy's brain is who
cooked cooked good luck with that I sure
hope you turn it darling if you need
help I'll be happy to help you but I
can't help you unless both of you're
right one to do it if you won't if one
of you you know filling in the hole
faster and the other ones digging it out
you ain't got a chance and that's what's
going on here you're scared to death
finally way too late you got scared to
death you should have been scared to
death for you sign any of those papers
but now you're finally scared to death
and he still just walking along like a
bear in the woods or something I don't
know what he's walking along like I
can't even come up with a good metaphor
right now he's lost I'm thinking of that
guy the bear in Jungle Book you know
just it's the bare necessities I can't
sing it but that's kind of you know just
did he win down south we call it did he
bopping along you know and crap runs
over you like a train when you do that
you're just gonna be train wreck that's
what you're going to be
so I sure hope you guys address this
please address it for your sake it
doesn't affect me but my gosh what a
mess no and Yuri they're gonna happen to
the mess oh the mess is gonna happen to
you there is no in-between it's physics
it's coming it's coming hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]